nos élus qui met à lui n'était pas déjà
il est très amoureux de lui depuis très
longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour raisonner le concert était
incroyable qu'est ce que j'en dis non
non non j'ai dû se faire mal en plus la
pauvre on voit qu'elle est en voie que
les muscles et c'est une artiste et ça a
dû lui arriver mais effectivement alors
forcément quand on est un peu méchant ça
nous a donné une petite idée c'est
revoir voilà quelques vidéos de lachute
sacem c'était dans l'émission x factor s
établit en sirène
et sa chaise s'est cassé la gueule c'est
quand même katy perry et c'est grotesque
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ardente été les buteurs american idol et
chaque année ils font ce que si elle
disney avait pas venu en sirène comme ça
parce qu'elle s'est dit tiens voilà
justin bieber qui fait une chute et en
concert voilà un groupe de gospel
chanter sur scène ils devaient descendre
en ange tombé du ciel bas il est tombé
[Applaudissements]
ouais il mauvais
oui alors on me dit fictivement dans
leur aide fake mais pas que oui que
jegham les spécialistes origine tout ça
il devait pas tomber de si oui là donc
j'étais pex était prévu que cette chute
mettront
d'accord là ça ressemble un peu à
l'organisation de ppm peu en prime du
centre entame une grue les maires de toi
tu crois effectivement que tu vois kane
dans ses yeux quand il se relève il dit
rien ouais on a poussé un peu sur la
vanne oui mais voilà là en permanence ou
du français bien sûr shy'm sa shy'm ça
c'est quand même génial
surtout bébé on va en parler tu étais
amoureuse de toi donc maintenant c'est
une autre qui viennent quatre mille
balles par mois bakhit l'a piqué mais
qu'est ce tu gees
c'est laura heureusement sitôt votre ce
qu'a découvert vous avez pu enfin vivre
un véritable conte de fées
[Musique]
en moto
et je peux me reposer un petit peu
qu'ils veulent moi
un amour indestructible basé sur
l'échangé la communication
et tu tombes vraiment amoureux de thomas
mais en fait on n'est pas du tout rire
et soeurs on est oui trente secondes
pour se traiter très fort et je commence
à tomber amoureuse de lui sauf que le
secret est pas encore découvert par les
autres habitants de la maison donc on se
retrouve demain tout simplement avoir
cette relation moi je suis amoureuse de
vie mais je ne peux le dire la personne
parce qu'on ne peut pas être amoureuse
de son frère non et du coup huit
semaines après le secret est découvert
et du coup je peux lui annoncer que chez
amoureuse de lui je suis trop contente
et je veux prendre le vent de l'année
devant 5 millions de téléspectateurs
parce que l'amour de qui lui l'était pas
déjà il est très amoureux de lui depuis
très longtemps
[Rires]
alors qu'il a dit une phrase qui m'a
fait rire beaucoup boire son sperme
quatre fois par jour
c'est le médecin qui a conseillé à kim
kardashian de boire du sport
voilà voilà voilà
[Rires]
du coup et parce que du coup
on passe à autre chose ou bien mais je
peux vous dire que kim elle a dit
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est ce matin
qu'elle était capable de manger ses
propres son propre logique cela les
jeunes jusqu'à et on est quand même tous
d'accord pour dire que pas pardon gp
ratés sur être chaud mais kim kardashian
et les onglets l'aller comment vos tant
que gens peuvent s'intéresser à moi je
savais pas qu'ils disaient ils
s'appellent tout ça vraiment pour le
coup là le ne faites pas ça chez vous
merci
la norme et les femmes qui sont prêtes à
boire le
diable jamais vous rendez compte aux
états unis ça se passe comme ça se fait
plus on n'est pas encore dans les
américains soirée spéciale alors on fera
pas de sondages mais c'étaient de bonnes
idées ont balisé
tout ça c'est laisser coincer les
goodies c'est le marketing ne jubilez
thing du jubilé il se rappelle que tu
renvoies turturro bien là ce soir tu
étais aujourd'hui pour nous concerne
pour l'instant etf avez vous plus ou
moins qu à condat les retombées vont se
chiffrer non 331 millions de en
redressant 100 millions à 130 millions
55 minutes à milhas sai on estime à plus
d'un million avec 9,6 millions revient à
plus d'un milliard est ressassé du
placement j'ai fait des associations et
tous de tous les bénéfices là quand même
mais ce sera probablement la royal
collection l'attaquant jeudi milliards
d'euros ça ne revient pas vraiment
uniquement dans les caisses du palais
royal pour le poids c'est tous confondus
c'est-à-dire les imams et les deux tels
les billets de travaux d'assainissement
oui c'est tout confondu en tout cas ce
que l'on peut dire c'est que des dix
lignes téléphoniques de buckingham ne
répondent plus elles sont saturées et
les cadeaux que l'on peut encore
éventuellement avoir et bien vous pouvez
passer commande vous pouvez payer mais
vous n'êtes pas sûr d'être 8 sur le
marché noir rien moisson
[Applaudissements]
le gode il est la regarde elle est là
mais comme le dit dans l'ariège c'est
que tu avais raison tout ça est en train
d'être vendu maintenant sur des marchés
nord sur vintage ça c'est cet euro non
alors c'est une paille en plastique avec
un bout de